this resort is suffering from success
everybody wants to be here
champagne problems took my daughter
calls and champagne problems we can with
that frequently
at the Four Seasons Hualalai there used
to be three ways for you to get yourself
to this pool one stay at the hotel to
become a homeowner and buy a condo or
villa or three no a homeowner and rent
or borrow their place it was getting
crowded the Four Seasons they felt they
were losing their exclusiveness they
needed to decrease the population the
resort says that it's very crowded I
don't agree with that I'm one of three
people in the spin class I'm the only
person swimming in the lap pool my house
is on the golf course I think I've seen
five golfers go by since this morning
still the Four Seasons thought it was
getting too crowded for their hotel
guests especially during peak seasons
and so they started charging homeowners
a steep daily access fee for their
visitors so for example our house sleeps
10 people if I want to lend my house to
my nephew he has to pay $2,500 a day to
use the resort's restaurants and the gym
the spa area one of the nice advantages
of having a villa like ours was that we
could rent it and I'm not crying poor
but it's a very expensive place to live
oh we were just you know got financial
problems too bad Plus this really hit a
nerve with certain homeowners who'd been
experiencing hostilities down at the
hotel a few years ago being a homeowner
meant something those of us who've made
a commitment and spent millions of
dollars I think we're allowed to be
first in line in a lot of ways this year
we were greeting each other down by the
beach tree pool and a woman came over
from the pool house and said if you
people don't keep your voices down we're
going to have to call security we all
looked at each other and I said where am
I
this isn't the walleye that I used to be
at it's just different now for some the
management had gone too far I filed a
class-action lawsuit so it might seem
like a bunch of rich people arguing
about beach chairs but it's really more
fundamental property rights issues than
that we happen to be rich but that's not
why we're fighting nobody should have
that kind of power over another
population in the community the
homeowner is there's so many of us we
are so wealthy is billions of dollars in
homes in here how dare the Four Seasons
control the financial management of
individual homes for the sake of the
resort
that doesn't work that doesn't work the
lawyers for Hualalai deny all of the
lawsuits claims arguing that the resort
has the right to change guest rates and
many homeowners support Hualalai we
support the resort and the management I
mean these facilities don't come for
free when management's and it's a copy
of the actual lawsuit I think I cried my
way through it from my heart
for now some homeowners are questioning
whether they can tolerate this new
higher cost of living with wealthy
people when you make things hard for
them they'll just walk away they'll put
their place on the market and go to
their other home or their other resort
if we do sell and I don't know if we
will but if we do sell I would sure like
to come back maybe for Christmas you
know I'll be a hotel guest
maybe they'll treat me better